by now i think we all know about spacex
and blue origin's ambitions to create a
reliable satellite internet service
spacex has already launched thousands of
starling satellites
and they are currently in the process of
rolling out a beta version
meanwhile blue origin amazon seems to be
years behind
as they haven't even reached orbit yet
considering other company situations
people love to make fun of blue origin
for making very minimal progress
but what's ironic is that both spacex
and blue origin
are decades late to the game as bill
gates was trying to launch his own
satellite internet service called
teledesk way back in the early 1990s
so here's the story of the time bill
gates tried to launch his own starlink
but unfortunately failed
teledesk was originally founded in june
of 1990
by business mogul craig mccall craig had
previously hit it big with this company
because cellular which was a leader
within the cellular telephone market
his father had actually founded the
company way back in 1966 as a cable
television provider
and though he did find a good amount of
success within that industry
it wasn't until craig shifted the focus
of the company to the cellular market
that they became a major player at t
would end up buying mikko cellular for
12.6 billion dollars in 1993
making craig a billionaire so clearly
craig was not messing around when it
came to teledesk
he was previously able to identify an
upcoming boom within the cellular market
which made him a billionaire and now he
aimed to do the exact same thing with
the satellite internet market
the first couple of years were pretty
slow as craig was still very much
focused on because cellular
but after the acquisition in 1993 craig
would turn his full focus
onto teledesk and he would onboard a
notable partner
which was of course bill gates in 1994
both craig and bill gates would invest 5
million dollars into the company
and with that greg would begin to pitch
the idea to countries
and companies around the world but wait
a minute
both craig and bill were billionaires
with an abundance of connections within
the business world
so why do they need to raise money and
bring on investors
well similar to elon's vision with
starlink today craig's vision was simply
so massive that even two billionaires
couldn't handle it by themselves
you see craig wasn't looking to launch
10 or 20 satellites
no he wanted to launch 840 satellites
at the time this was more than the total
number of satellites in space
and accordingly it came with a hefty
setup cost of 9 billion
though their project was extremely
expensive it promised to make internet
access basically universal
no matter how remote a location was
people could use teledesk services
given the company's vision and the
people behind the company
many investors would give the company a
shot boeing would pledge to invest up to
100 million dollars
saudi prince of walid bin talal would
invest 200 million dollars
and motorola would invest a massive 750
million dollars
ironically the company had no working
product
but it was able to raise nearly 2
billion mostly because bill gates
and craig mccall were involved aside
from raising a crap ton of money
bill and craig were even able to
convince governments to set aside a
portion of the electromagnetic spectrum
that would be exclusively used by
teledesk's network clearly
bill and craig were not messing around
and now
it was time to execute the duo was very
much aware of how important execution
was
so they chose the best partner they
could which was of course
boeing boeing was given most of the
responsibility of designing the
satellites
building the satellites and launching
the satellites boeing
already had extensive experience working
on space projects so this project was a
piece of cake for them
teledesk's proposed satellites were
super small and didn't have to be
launched that far into space
so boeing planned to simply launch
clusters of satellites on large existing
boosters
which is not that different from
starling missions today
while boeing was working on developing
teledesk satellites a relatively small
teledesk team of 100 employees
focused on getting regulatory approval
and hitting other technical requirements
everything seemed to be quickly
progressing forward but this is when
teledesk would face
its first major setback as we previously
discussed
tadasak wanted to launch 840 super small
satellites
but boeing insisted on launching fewer
larger satellites
given that boeing was teledesk's primary
contractor at this point
tadasak would agree and reduce the
proposed number of satellites to just
300.
the official explanation for the switch
was that boeing's proposed plan
was superior to telesex original idea
however
a former employee of teledesk would
eventually reveal in 2016
that this explanation was a complete lie
the primary reason
boeing insisted so heavily on launching
larger satellites is because legacy
satellite manufacturers
already had large satellites in
inventory now manufacturing smaller
satellites like teledesk wanted
wouldn't be that hard for them but the
manufacturers were heavily opposed to
this idea
you see these traditional satellite
manufacturers had a monopoly within the
industry
and it was nearly impossible for a
startup to compete against them
as the bar of entry was so high however
if these manufacturers expanded to
producing smaller satellites
the bar for entry would be significantly
lowered which could lead them to losing
market share to startups
aside from this the manufacturers were
also fearful that if they started to
produce smaller satellites
the us military would also prefer to buy
the smaller ones which had much lower
profit margins
so basically tel desect was forced to
switch to larger satellites because
satellite manufacturers didn't want to
let go
of their monopoly we're not exactly sure
how much these larger satellites caused
but assuming that the cost to launch all
the satellites was constant at 9 billion
each satellite costs approximately 30
million dollars
to put this in perspective starling
satellites are expected to cost 250 000
per satellite and already cost less than
500 thousand dollars per satellite
starling satellites are more comparable
to the smaller satellites telesec wanted
to launch
but even then the cost per satellite is
insanely high
if we spread the 9 billion over 840
satellites like originally anticipated
we get nearly 11 million per satellite
which is over 20 times the cost of a
starling satellite
today and the truth is satellite costs
have not dropped 20 fold over the past
two decades
so teledesk was more or less getting
ripped off when it came to launching
satellites
aside from getting ripped off into red
flags started to pop up
that people weren't actually that
interested in a satellite-based internet
service
in 1999 two satellite companies named
iridium communications
and ico would file for bankruptcy these
guys weren't targeting the satellite
internet market
but they were targeting the satellite
phone market at first glance
you might think that maybe they ran out
of funding or that investors backed away
however this was actually still before
the dot-com crash
so funding wasn't that hard to secure
the real problem with these companies
was that there was very little demand
for their services the only people
buying their services were people
working on fishing boats and people
working on oil rigs
let's also keep in mind that during this
time period having a cell phone
connection was a much higher priority
than having an internet connection so if
these cell phone companies couldn't find
much demand
it was unlikely that tal desect would
find much demand with the internet
and this does make sense providing
internet to every corner of the world
is a very noble cause but how many
people living in rural
villages in the late 1990s wanted to
access internet
had a device that can access the
internet and could afford to pay for a
monthly internet subscription
from an outside perspective it's pretty
clear why there was lackluster demand
but craig didn't really see this side of
the picture
in fact he actually thought that the
bankruptcies of iridium and ico were
great opportunities
and he would spend the next couple of
years trying to acquire these two
companies
at one point he would even invest 74.6
million dollars into iridium to keep it
afloat
clearly the other investors of tal
desect weren't thrilled to see because
focusing on keeping these random
companies alive
instead of focusing on tadasak this
would even lead to an investor filing a
lawsuit
against mccaw for using teledesk's
resources to aid in his personal
interest
in ico things were falling apart rapidly
and teledesk was yet to even launch a
single satellite and
when you think that things can't get
worse the dot-com crash would happen
investors were losing millions of
dollars left and right during the
dot-com crash
and they had no intention of continuing
to fantastic
meanwhile bill gates had just stepped
down from his role as microsoft ceo
and he was looking to focus on
philanthropy so he really didn't have
that much interest in trying to save the
company
either fortunately though todd essec had
not yet locked in on a satellite
contract with any company
they did originally work with boeing but
then they switched to motorola
and eventually they switched to
teosilenia space
ironically their constant switching
would turn out to be a good thing
since they hadn't locked into a contract
with any of these companies
they actually still had a lot of the
cash they raised considering this unique
situation
investors would decide to pull the plug
when they still could and
given the structure in which money is
raised for startups early investors
would actually end up profiting from
their investment
despite the company not doing anything
late investors however
would lose money but even those losses
were quite minimal
especially compared to many companies
that closed down during the dot-com
crash
at the end of the day teledesk aimed to
revolutionize global internet
but honestly it was just way too early
as in
decades too early combine this with the
fact that teledesk didn't have launch
capability
in-house and the fact that tadasak was
more of a side project for mccaw
and gates it's not hard to see whether
project never worked out
it is however insane to think that these
two geniuses had the idea to basically
launch starlink
30 years ago did you guys know about
teledesk comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys are
confident that starlink will have a much
better fate
and of course consider joining our
discord community to such as future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one